It's great to welcome to the program today,
Martin Dury, who is a former CIA analyst.
It's an author of the revolt of the public
first published in 2014 and updated in 2018.
Uh great. To have you on Martin, I appreciate
your time.
Happy to be here.
So when you look back at some of the revolts
of the last decades, so you know, occupy wall
street, the Hong Kong protests, Arab spring,
we're seeing unrest in Paris right now. Do
you see any sort of common thread between
them?
Well, what we have is, um, essentially, uh,
uh, eruption, uh, from below that's made possible
by the fact I think our, um, uh, our systems
of governments, which are, whether they're
democratic or dictatorial based on, uh, the
industrial model. This is when when our government
took its form, can't withstand the amount
of information or that the digital world has
thrown at it. So they have very much in common.
They have a, they seem to be, the model is
almost like a, an internet chat room where
there's no leaders, there are no spokespersons,
there are no programs, certainly no ideologies,
but they're very anti ideology. So as you
can tell, I am not a young person when I was
young, if you were good, could have a radical,
a movement, you needed essentially a mini
hierarchy that you wanted to overthrow the
government with today. That is not at all
a what you see in any of those four revolts.
That's interesting. And so in a sense it's
the technology of the last 10 years that have
enabled a, I guess we would call it a flatter
infrastructure rather than a hierarchical
one to take hold.
Yeah. I think, uh, it's a coalition between
information enabled by technology and systems
of, and it's not just government. I think
you could say the same about every major institution
that that modern society, uh, uh, is sustained
by, um, systems that require control over
the information in their own domains. And
because of this enormous tsunami of information
generated by, um, uh, the digital universe,
uh, that semi monopoly of information has
been lost. And the second that happened, these
institutions, including government, they could
in politics and political parties say a half
laps into what I've called the crisis of authority.
It seems that this is a double edged sword
though in the sense that on the one hand the
internet has greatly democratized reporting,
information, availability, diversity of sources,
so on and so forth. And at the same time,
this has been a catalyst for the crisis of
fake news and disinformation, the inability
to distinguish fact fiction, opinion and reporting,
so on and so forth. How, what's your sense
of the balance of those two forces?
Well, I mean I think there is no balance.
I think we are in a totally fractured environment.
When you have a crisis of authority, you are
bound to get a crisis of uncertainty. Okay.
So, um, you people live in what I call the
public. Uh, it, I don't mean by that, that
people, I don't mean by that the masses, the
public is essentially the old mass audience.
Um, which in my day when I was younger, it
was like an enormous mirror, uh, that you
saw yourself reflected in. Well, that mirror
has shattered as fallen. It has and the public
lives in the broken pieces and each piece
seems to have its own way of collecting and
analyzing information that can be very different
from all the others. The pieces are mutually
hostile and barely sometimes connect about
what is a fact and what isn't.
One of the things that I find really interesting
that you write about is that it is much easier
for large groups of the public to unify around
something that they are against, something
that they reject than it is around a sort
of positive things that, that they want to
do. And um, this, you know, when you, when
you look at, for example, local news and you
see how sensationalism and stories of crime
and negativity do far better than other types
of stories, there seems to be something inherent
there to the way that people, uh, are motivated
to say to their neighbor, Hey, did you see
this bad thing that's going on? That is much
more, uh, there's something about that that
spurs action much more than, Hey, let's get
together and do this positive thing. Do you
agree with that assessment and what, what
are the implications of that when it comes
to activism?
Well, when you look at that fractured environment
that just described, each one of those fragments
has its own. Um, you know, you could be the
tea party, you could be a feminist, you could
be a Bernie bro. There is very, very different
ways of uh, parsing information and data.
Um, and if you want to mobilize at unify,
there's very fractured environment. The only
way to do so is by being against, and there
is this tremendous swelling of um, anger against,
uh, the established order. So what, what you
have in many of these four bolts, and you
can start with Tahrir square in Egypt and
all the way to Hong Kong, you have people
from every kind of a political opinion, but
they are unified against, they want to overthrow
the system as they exist. The danger as you
point out is if you're against and you are,
as these people tend to be not interested
in alternatives, then you can run into what
I call nihilism, which is basically the belief
that you destruction of the system for its
own sake is a form of progress. And I mean,
I leave you to consider that. I don't think
it is.
Well, that seems to be one of the big divisions
that exists on the left right now, which is
the, uh, work with the system to improve it
mentality compared to the burn it all down
to eventually rebuild something better. Uh,
uh, ideology. I don't have any moral imperative
one way or the other. I think if you look
at history, the incrementalism seems to have
achieved more as I understand it, but I'm
not, uh, ideologically or emotionally attached
to one movement or the other, but that, that
seems to be a very prominent discussion happening
right now on the left.
Well, you burn it all down. Then what [inaudible]
the difference between today and say 1917
you were a Bolshevik or, or even 1959, you
were a Castro list, you know, is you have,
uh, an organization, uh, a program and a set
of ideologies and you want power to put those
in place. Um, you tear it all down today.
What do you get? You, you basically have people
who are activists in condemning the government
and then turning around and asking the same
government that they are condemning, well,
we need you to do this and that and the other
versus I want to take over the era of revolution
in my, in my humble opinion as an analyst,
uh, pretty much died in 1991. So you're not
going to do the Bolsheviks or, or Havana,
Cuba and 59 over again. So what the public
can't yet do that maybe it should be working
towards is articulate positive demands. What
is it that it can, um, actually, um, share
together, uh, when, when it rises up like
a dozen Hong Kong, like it doesn't, uh, and
she live for example.
Well, the, the one that now seems to be potentially
on the cusp is the movement in the United
States for some kind of single payer healthcare
system or Medicare for all, which is as, as
it sees itself anyway, it sees itself as a
positive movement. It wants to do something
good. It is a movement that believes it can
improve things for people if the system is
changed. But at the same time it's been born
in opposition to the status quo. So D, would
you consider that movement of movement for
something or is it still a movement against,
I mean, I, I find that kind of a circular
thing. You're saying that the, the people
in charge are, uh, corrupt us. You should,
the charge has made, uh, the, they are incompetent.
Uh, they are distant and self-serving. Okay.
And yet you're saying, well, but, but I have
this massive government program that I want
to hand to them that that just doesn't work.
I mean, my feeling is you're talking policy
and the, that part of what depresses me a
lot about the current political environment.
This, that's the standard way of talking.
You talk policy, um, um, you know, for Medicare
I'm against Medicare, I want to up it, I want
to lower it. Um, that's fine. But what you
have today is a tremendous rebellion against
the distance between the top of the system
of the bottom and any policy you put in there,
the massive amount of distress is going to
generate. It's going to spark another revolt.
You do what you do. We're just suggesting
you could get another tea party probably.
Well, but, but that, let's break that down
a little bit because I think you're right
that there is, there's a rejection of the
status quo. There's a rejection of the, what
have become the structures of power and the
hierarchical difference and inequality.
I really think the people who actually doing
it,
that the movement for something like Medicare
for all, they don't see the government necessarily
as the problem. I think they see the government
as having been co-opted by for profit corporations
and that's what they want to remove. It's
not the government that they want to remove.
So I don't know that I see the inconsistency
that you're pointing out there.
Well, I mean, I, I, I, my research, uh, with,
I mean now dozens of these revolts, uh, it's
pretty clear that the government, I mean the
data's there here in the U S to government
levels of distrust are just crashing through
the floor. I mean, I won't say they're at
rock bottom. They could still fall a little
bit that somewhere between 20 and 30% of,
of, of the, uh, electorate trust their elected
government. Think about that. So what you
are saying though is you're, you're, you conceiving
of some gigantic program that you will, are
then going to be handing off to this body
that you absolutely distrust. I think before
we get to the program, we need to recreate
reform, uh, the system so that the distance
is lowered and trust. And so some kind of,
you can reconcile the public to our forms
of democracy.
What would be steps that could be taken to
remove that debt, that distance and to increase
trust in the institutions of power? Wouldn't,
I mean it seems to me that separating, uh,
the corporate, uh, a sort of hierarchy and
influence on government would be a great first
step.
Yeah. I mean that's the problem is in this
fractured environment, nobody's going to trust
you that it's really happening. The second
you stop seeing it out in front, you're going
to start believing that it's happening behind
closed doors. So what you need is a, um, uh,
a system that I would say to be a good beginning
would be push as much decision making down
to as local a level as possible. So there
are as few levels between you and the power
that is making decisions as you can get it
to be. All right. I mean, how many hundreds
of levels of, of uh, bureaucracy are there
between you and the president of the United
States? Uh, he might as well live in Mount
Olympus with the gods is the, the Emmanuel
Macron ambition, right? Um, so that has to
change. And the one way to start changing
that is to bring down a decision making as
local as possible where people are as visible
as possible and react as immediately as possible
to pressure from below from the voters.
The book is fascinating. It's called the revolt
of the public first published in 2014 and
updated in 2018 we've been speaking with the
books author, former CIA analyst Martin. Gary
Martin, you so much. I really
do appreciate your time today. Yeah, I love
being here.